you know today history talks a really
important event you've got a movie
coming out you've got so much on your
plate but you prioritized being here why
is it so important well first of all I
really love the History Channel they've
been extraordinary first of all I love
watching but
um they've been extraordinary they're
they're they were the very first people
to fund our school that we're building
and they were doing in Los Angeles yeah
the Royal Academy so they've actually
really stepped up always and they sort
of seem to be on the right side of
history and so I'm I'm really proud to
be here and sort of help and represent
them
and you know you are such an incredible
humanitarian and your wife I'm all too
you guys looked incredible together when
you think about the contributions that
both of you have made on camera and off
what part of your history do you hope
people remember most
I don't know I'm not quite sure that
that's for me to try to figure out I
think someone else has to figure out
what the what to remember I just hope
they don't remember Batman
do you know what I'm saying
just joking well I am the best Batman
though you know I mean do you see an
Affleck come on look at me look at him
come on no uh I listen I don't know
we'll figure it out
very very excited about to get to
Paradise now your good pal Julia Roberts
is here as well yes
it's in kovid you're doing a press tour
you're now here at history talks oh
there's been this restraining order now
so that's why we're not here together
she's very excited to see you in that
partnership for years I mean what does
that mean to you she's a really good she
and her whole family are friends and I
really love uh I love their whole family
and she's just a you know she was uh
when we were shooting in in Australia
she lived down below us and she just
would come up and literally take the
kids out for ice cream with my wife you
know I heard a rumor that she became the
fifth Clooney of that trip yeah I know I
can't shake her she's like uh yeah
exactly she's like the Beetle and the
last time we spoke with you you made a
great joke you said that your your twin
five-year-old are actually smarter than
you are that's not even a joke that's I
wish that was a joke are they here on
this trip with you I mean when you think
about today's event and how important it
is we're going to be learning from some
of the best world leaders what are some
of the values that you and Amal are
really working hard to instill in those
kids well the same thing I think that
everybody wants to instill in their kids
which is to pay attention to other
people you know my family was always the
rules were always challenge people in
power and defend people with less power
and that's it and if you can do that
you've had a good life you know happy
early anniversary yeah that's right yeah
eight years eight years they said it
wouldn't last I never said that you guys
already I never would say that I
wouldn't say that never you two seem
like you are just truly soul mates in
the most beautiful way so when you think
back on the last eight years what has
made it so magical well everything about
my wife is sort of magical is I think
everybody has come to realize once they
see her in here and see what she stands
for and you know so everything about it
there's not a there's nothing there's
not a downside to it it's all been
magical and I know you're a good man
you're a romantic man do you have
something planned for next week yeah oh
so I'm going to tell you and then she
finds out she's gonna watch
Entertainment Tonight on Monday no this
is just a disaster it's a disaster
[Music]
foreign